jerry dholak covers the Steelers for the
Pittsburgh post-gazette he joins us now
Jerry let me start with the Minka
Fitzpatrick trade was this in the works
with Ben still being in the lineup well
dan good morning I will say this that
the Steelers had been in search of a
number three safety because they didn't
feel they had any depth at the position
but then when he became available I
think what you're looking at here is
their regular starter Sean Davis is a
free agent at the end of the year they
weren't going to resign him he also has
a shoulder injury but I think looking at
the big picture they felt they could get
a player of Minka Fitzpatrick's caliber
that they wouldn't get a shot at you
know in the draft and what surprised me
though Dan about the deal was that is
that just goes against everything that
Dan Rooney always believed in which is
you never trade away a future number one
that was the most surprising aspect of
men deal to me but why they made it
beyond that didn't fit flooring well I
don't know if you agree with me but I
thought that they must think a lot more
of Mason Rudolph then most people do and
maybe they feel like they got a
first-round talent on a quarterback
they're not going to take a step back
they're gonna you know bring in
Fitzpatrick and they're still going to
compete for this division it do you
agree with that do you see that that
good because you have to you have to
feel like Rudolph can play or why are
you making that trade right now well I
think the flipside I will agree with you
in this regard and I I do believe they
feel that Mason Rudolph is going to
surprise some people you know I'm not
going to sit here and predict 11:00 and
5:00 but I think they feel they could be
or should be okay with Mason Rudolph the
flipside of that could be that because
of Ben's injury they feel they need to
upgrade their defense because they're
going to need their defense and a
running game carry them through this
period and and neither which have been
very solid you know here in the first
couple games so
exactly the case - but I will say they
like mason rudolph and he's really
progressed a lot from year one to year
two what is Ben's future with this team
well you know you'll be 38 when he comes
back from the injury we shall see you
know I was told yesterday that the you
know the organization does not believe
that the injuries career-threatening
knowing been with a challenge any time
he has challenged on everything he
responds he takes it personally and I
and I believe you know III you know
history is not shown me not to doubt him
and so I think that you know I think
he'll come back he's really worked the
last three or four years with his
nutrition is died with working out he's
in the best shape he has been the last
couple three four years of his of his
professional career his arm is as strong
as ever now after the surgery we shall
see but other guys have had this surgery
and come back from it and well you know
we'll see how it plays out but I I
believed you'll come back he said he
wants to play out his contract which
takes him through 2021
and and I believe talking to Jerry
dholak he covers the Steelers for the
Pittsburgh post-gazette just got word
the Giants have named Daniel Jones as
their starting quarterback Giants will
be on the road in Tampa who do you think
the Steelers look at as the team to beat
in their division with the Ravens and
the Browns well I really think they look
at it as you know it to the proven
winners and then that would be the
Baltimore Ravens and certainly what
we've seen in the first two weeks you
know what would indicate that needed
strengthened their opinion so I think
they always look at it that way that's
not to say they don't discount
you know what the Browns have been able
to do but you know they're never going
to say this but I think they probably
subscribe to the theory that look until
you show me you can do it I'm not going
to sit here and hand you anything
whereas Baltimore has shown that you
know their offense it has changed you
know the way they play the game has
changed and sir
with Lamar Jackson and the weapons that
they've given him with Marquis Brown I
think there are more dangerous team
offensively hmm
that they had been so but I don't think
there's any question they still look at
the Ravens as the team to beat then in a
division Jerry have fun today play nice
we appreciate your time thank you
Jerry dholak he covers the Steelers
Pittsburgh post-gazette for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]